would you let a robot see 3PO for
example work on your teeth well now you
may have a chance it's not actually
C-3PO no it's r2d not the robotic like
vacuum cleaner either okay a Las Vegas
Dennis is the first to offer an FDA
cleared robotic surgical system here in
the U.S Candace Charles joining us live
from Discovery Dental uh we haven't put
you in the dentist chair yet
good news Heather I am not into Dental
chair today I'm not going to give that
kind of demonstration but I do have
someone else who will be giving that
demonstration Tracy has been doing a
fantastic job really she's been in this
chair the whole entire time letting Dr
Mercer help out show the demonstration
of what this amazing system can do this
is yomi the robot or as some of the
folks out here I've been calling yomi
the homie helps out with dental
implementation making the process not
only easier but less painful keyword
guys less painful keywords I guess and
I'm joined by Dr Andy Mercer now he is
the first in Nevada to get this uh
system in his office tell us a little
bit how it works it works by simply it
works like more like a GPS system for
implants okay so it helps us kind of
guide the right position
to show you that we can go ahead and
demonstrate one case right now perfect
perfect and he's got his team here with
him Bertha Stephanie and Buddy from yomi
that's going to be showing you a little
bit about how this works but I did want
to bring in a patient who's actually
done the procedure last week if you
believe it or not uh Terry Thompson
thank you so much for joining us tell me
a little bit about how it went for you
and what it was like you got to tell me
too girl it wasn't really painful or was
it less painful it was less painful the
very first day
um the day after I had pain but that
Thursday the pain had subsided
tremendously and right now I have no
pain can't even feel the implants in
nice okay was it weird having a robot in
your mouth
yes yeah yes yes it was
but everyone had explained the procedure
to me and they made me more relaxed okay
the cool thing that I've seen uh do this
here was that the uh robot kind of moves
with you as well yes it does so you saw
that you felt that and everything oh wow
okay okay so you're feeling good now so
that's the good news thank you so much
Jay for chatting with us this morning
really cool Discovery and Technology
dental technology advancement right here
in the state of Nevada you guys we've
seen in a few other states but the first
year in the States was pretty awesome to
get a chance to see this and it's at
Discovery Dental off of Lake Mead of
course I got you covered with all the
details on our website 8newsnow.com for
now live from Discovery Dental off of
Lake Mead I'm Candace Charles 8 News Now